Having to close or navigate the tab
to get the service worker to update
is a bit of a pain during development.
But thankfully,
there are ways to make it easier.
I'm going to make a change to the
console look in the service worker, and
then back in the page I'm
going to hit refresh.
Now there's a new
service worker waiting.
You can tell the difference here as the
active service worker has this red icon
and the waiting one is,
I don't know is that teal?
You can tell I'm not a designer.
It's waiting because the tab is
still using the active version, but
rather than close this tab or
navigate it to another origin,
I'm going to reload the page
while holding Shift.
This loads the page but
bypasses the service worker.
This behavior is part of
the service worker spec, so
it should work in any browser
that supports service workers.
This is handy for two reasons.
One, it's a quick way to test changes
that are unrelated to the service
worker, such as minor CSS changes.
And two, because this tab is no longer
controlled by the service worker,
it let's the waiting
service worker take over.
We can see this in dev tools, the teal
service worker has progressed to active.
Now if I refresh normally,
the request goes through the new service
worker and we get the updated log.
Now's probably a good time to
talk about this ERR_FILE_EXISTS
thing in the console there.
That's just Chrome saying it's
checked the service worker and
there were no changes.
Showing an error for this is a bug,
but it isn't breaking anything.
Hopefully this bug will be fixed by
the time you go through this course.
So, Shift+Refresh is an easier
way to get updates, but
Chrome's dev tools has
an even easier way.
In the Sources tab, check out this
little service worker panel here.
There's an option called,
Force update on page load.
This changes the service worker life
cycle to be developer-friendly rather
than user-friendly.
In this mode when you hit refresh,
rather than refreshing the page,
it fetches a service worker, treats it
as a new version whether it's changed or
not, and let's it become active straight
away, and then the page refreshes.
That means I can make a change to
the console log, say, Yo Everyone,
and then back in the page hit refresh
and I get those changes straight away.
No Shift+Refresh, no closing tabs.
This change in behavior only happens
while dev tools is open, but
it makes viewing quick
changes really easy.
However, we need to bear in mind
it's not the same life cycle
users will be getting.
Later in the course, we'll look at
optimizing the user experience, but
first, let's do some more exciting
things with the service worker.
In the next chapter,
we'll look at hijacking requests and
doing our own thing.